[Musique]
après des années de silence politique le
déploiement de la consigne élargi
entrera en vigueur dans un an si tout va
bien les convainc de métal le plastique
contenant multicouches et de verre va y
consigner 25 fans pour les bouteilles de
vins et spiritueux 17 pour les
contenants de jus de l'est et d'eau
voilà ce que voudront bientôt vos
contenants vides au québec en ce moment
au linge légumes dans une canette époque
ont signé pour une boisson gazeuse une
bière dans la même gamelle ses consignes
et donc d'un nouveau système le système
moderniser va-tout sauvaitre cosmologie
légumes le jus qu'à sa solidité d'où le
vin et les spiritueux karel ménard la
conseilla dossier qui vous tient car une
victoire pour ce militant pro consignes
depuis 30 aujourd'hui on parle qu'on
consomme environ un milliard de
bouteilles d'eau par année au québec là
dessus les derniers chiffres officiels
c'est seulement 300 millions de
bouteilles d'eau en plastique qui sont
effectivement acheminer des fans russes
l'âge avec le tri à la source le nombre
de contenants consignés annuellement
bondira de 2,5 à 4,5 milliards c'est
tout ce déroule comme prévu à compter du
printemps 2023 tous les contenants de
prêtes à boire de 100 millilitres à 2
litres seront consignés mais pour y
arriver il reste beaucoup de travail et
la marge d'erreur est minime selon ce
représentant des chaînes d'alimentation
faut que ça fonctionne céret du premier
faucon jour 1 la machine soit prête à
acquérir le consommateur et que ça
fonctionne sinon il risque de perdre la
confiance du consommateur et les risques
de bris de service est vraiment
problématique
nous permettre d'améliorer le taux de
recyclage de s'assurer qu'on une matière
qui est plus peur c'est sûr qu'à la saq
on se préoccupe particulièrement du
verre c'est l'amateur qu'on est surtout
en marché
le problème avec le système de la
collecte sélective actuelle c'est que la
matière récupérée et mélangés dans le
bac dans le camion au centre de tri ce
qui cause la contamination de la matière
seulement 30 % de celui-ci peut être
recyclé maintenant la prochaine étape de
ça c'est de s'assurer que les
infrastructures en aval suivent aussi et
qu'on puisse transformer cette matière
là pour en faire quelque chose de
nouveau ce qu'on souhaite il donne avec
ce projet là c'est mettre en place n'est
pas lui qui circule à locale si on est
capable et garde au québec pour
développer une industrie du recyclage au
québec l'incorporer de la matière qu'on
récupère les lieux de dépôt dans des
produits vendus au québec je pense que
tout le monde est gagnant ça va être bon
pour l'environnement ça va être bon pour
l'économie ça va être bon pour l'emploi
donc on est gagnant sur tous les
tableaux si on a accès à de la matière
de qualité et en quantité les joueurs ou
un club pour le risque lit ceci comme
une vérité absolue concrètement voici
comment cela va fonctionner les
québécois pourront rapporter tous leurs
contenants consignés dans un des 1500
points de dépôt qui seront créés c'est à
dire dans les saq les épiceries et les
commerces qui vendent des boissons
consignes et pour les détaillants qui
n'ont pas assez d'espacé en magasin il
sera possible de s'associer avec des
commerces environnants afin de créer un
point de retour partager les détaillants
de moins de 2500 pieds carrés n'auront
pas l'obligation d'accepter les retours
de contenants consignés en ce qu'il faut
pas que ce soit un peu difficile de
retourner qu'on acte de lâcheté donc ça
va être tenus en compte dans le
déploiement du nouveau système c'est sûr
c'est un changement de gestes parce que
le québécois vraiment intégré dans lance
et ses gestes le fait de déposer ces
contenants dans le bac bleu ça fait elle
va y ait 25 ans qu'on le fait ça fait
partie de nos presque de nos coutumes
jusqu'à un certain point et là c'est son
que ce qu'on demande un effort
additionnel
recyc québec s'est inspiré de ce qui se
fait dans les autres provinces et
ailleurs dans le monde pour développer
son programme de consignes et déployé
sept projets pilotes en ville et en
banlieue
pour financer des projets pilotes depuis
l'été 2000 21 on anticipe peut-être une
deuxième phase de pilote en donner de
l'information l'industrie qui s'assure
edwards qu'est ce qui fonctionne test
fonctionne moins bien
le système va tenir compte aussi des
spécificités régionales
donc chaque région a des particularités
ce qui va être bon pour montréal sera
pas nécessairement bon pour mon mari
pour granby donc ce sera pas un modèle
unique déployé dans toute la province
c'est intéressant parce qu'il faut que
le consommateur conçoivent aussi la
complexité de tout ça il pourrait
ajouter à la complexité
il y a aussi tout le transport de la
matière trier qui sera à réfléchir le
gouvernement exige que les producteurs
de boissons et les détaillants récupère
les trois quarts des contenants
consignés d'ici 2025 et 90% d'entre eux
d'ici 2030 faute de quoi ils pourront
être mises à l'amendé c'est vraiment une
tâche titanesque seco la salle comme un
chantier on doit définir des routes de
collecte on doit informer également le
consommateur où il peut retourner ces
contenants donc pour nous la de mettre
en place de ce système là créer les
bases de données pour que l'ego buzz
quand vous allez ramener votre conteneur
lago buzz soit capable de reprendre le
contenant savons tous qu'un contenants
consignés donc tous ces chantiers le
qu'on doit faire ça prend du temps et
c'est un peu notre inquiétude avec les
règlements qui a été déposée récemment
c'est que les échéanciers sont très
courts et on à part de pas avoir à ce
temps voir réaliser l'ensemble de ces
tâches la marche est très haute beaucoup
de choses à passer en très peu de temps
donc il ya beaucoup d'inquiétudes et je
vous dirai ou à certains égards ça donne
le vertige parce qu'il faut pas voir ce
ce système là comme un ajout comme une
annexe à la consigne actuelle au contrat
s'écrit réellement la création d'un
nouveau système et pourtant c'est
présentement tout le monde travaille
main dans la main alors que ce soit le
gouvernement les accuse les
embouteilleurs les détaillants
les producteurs de boissons qui même les
organisations qui sont dans la
transformation du baht
les frais et la responsabilité de la
modernisation du système de consigne
reviennent aux producteurs qui mettent
ces goûters sur le marché en principe ce
système se financera en bonne partie
lorsqu'il sera fonctionnel un système de
consigne à deux sources de revenus lang
ainsi les consignes non remboursés si un
citoyen consommateur décide de poster
son contenant ce sont des consignes non
remboursés on a aussi la valeur de la
matière en une matière meilleure qualité
on a une meilleure valeur de revente sur
les marchés donc le système va générer
plus de revenus grâce à la pensée où le
consommateur quant à lui ne devrait pas
payer plus cher soit assuré que s'il
fait le bon geste veut pas tourner votre
pensée il allait avoir 100 % du montant
nous on vise d'avoir des coffrets des
allemands 0 ce système s'auto finance le
repas des coffrets mais s'il ya des
matières plus problématique c'est
dommage mais va falloir mettre en place
en un coffret d'où l'importance de
participer au changement les gens
retournent écornant construit pour des
raisons environnementales sont
conscients de cette piste un geste
concret un geste peuvent profiter pour
réduire l'empreinte environnementale
puis vont faire le beau ranger cela on
est convaincu dans le 1000 m
est ce que vous y croyez bloqué dans un
an les consignes va être établie au
québec j'en ai vu de l'eau a coulé sous
les ponts en fait oui je suis optimiste
tour je suis réaliste honnêtement je
vais vous dire lorsque je vais mettre
une bouteille de vin dans une curieuse
et récupéré 26 ou de conseils de
vraiment juillet 3
[Musique]
à